talk about man just like
i know you've had a lot of of of people
tap in with you like
um like i said you're you're kind of the
known
i feel like it's the consensus amongst
the taste makers out here is like you're
up next
who's tapped in it's like kind of
surprised you that
was somebody who you were a fan of or
somebody who you were like oh my god
this person knows who the [ __ ] i am
it's funny that you said it earlier russ
tapped in recently russ
yeah russ a great guy solid dude he
shouted me out on twitter too
i saw that yeah i just saw that you're
right yeah
he just tweeted about you like too it
was yesterday the day before yeah yeah
shout out to russ that's crazy because i
watch
all his interviews and i'll be feeling
exactly how he'd be feeling about
everything so
shout out russ sean love because he
didn't have to do that
you know it's interesting with russ i
feel like he gets so much unwarranted
hate
and i'm like yo this guy's literally
giving you guys priceless
game that's crazy for free like [ __ ] you
can't pay for [ __ ] that nobody want to
tell you
who could tell you and he's just
spreading the game to everybody
and it's like yo you could do nothing
but appreciate somebody like that
too does that kind of um
staying independent or or or not
necessarily
going like the super major label route
to somebody like russ and what he you
know when he posted his tomb core [ __ ]
that [ __ ] was crazy
come on yeah that's pure motivation for
me when he
even when he tapped in i was telling her
i was like bro this is just reassurance
that i'm on the right path
yeah things like that yeah that's what
motivate me